So, as always, when I introduce a new concept to you, we'll have a little quiz about this here.
Now, it's always a bit difficult to ask, does P go into an infinite loop
when given I, so we'll slightly change that to the opposite question here,
and ask, does the program stop when given I?
So it's basically the other way around, and also it's the more
conventional definition of the halting problem, because
it's called the halting problem and not the infinite loop problem, to just ask 'does the program stop?'
Basically it's really just the opposite of an infinite loop.
So if a program stops, it does not go into an infinite loop,
and if it does not stop, it must be in some infinite loop.
But let's do the quiz now. So I have here 3 programs.
This is program 1, this is program 2, and program 3.
And, of course, I have inputs for those programs, and what I would like you to tell me
for each combination of a program and an input,
does the program stop when given this input?
It stops, then you can check here, if it does not stop, so if it goes into an infinite loop,
then I would like you to check here.